[Music]
foreign
so in the last lecture we derived the
forward Euler and backward Euler
numerical integration schemes
essentially using the finite difference
derivative approximation of DX DT
and we derived it for a generic
non-linear ode but we also looked at
what would happen if our Dynamics were
linear if x naught equals ax what would
these two different schemes be we found
that for example forward Euler is just
the first two terms in the Taylor series
of e to the a delta T now what we're
going to do is we're going to code this
up on a really simple example of the
spring Mass damper system so I'm going
to re-derive you know I've already done
this before but just really quickly just
as a refresher I'm going to derive the
equations of motion we're going to find
the a matrix this is a linear system so
we're going to be in this case here
where we're simulating these linear
versions of forward Euler and backward
Euler and we're just going to play
around with this a little bit in Python
and Matlab and see what happens for
example if I make delta T really big or
really small you know what happened
happens to these to these schemes and
I'm actually going to compare this to
something called the runga Cutta the the
fourth order runga Kata scheme which is
a much much higher accuracy higher order
scheme if you like it basically
approximates more terms in the Taylor
series it's a better approximation and
has better error properties and so we're
going to compare you know the solution
of this with these numerical schemes
with that higher order accurate
rangikatta scheme and then in the next
few lectures I'm going to talk about
you know deriving from Taylor series
what is the error of this approximation
and similarly what are the stability
properties of these systems for
different Delta T's okay good so I'm
just going to really really quickly
rederive uh from scratch the kind of
equations of motion here so we have some
mass m remember that our position is
measured from some rest position so X
the position here is measured with
respect to some rest position and we
have Newton's Second Law uh m x double
dot equals minus K times x that's our
spring constant K so that's the
restorative spring Force minus some
other constant x dot that's the the
damping coefficient C
and if you like we can
um move all of these over to one side
and divide by m and we get X double dot
uh plus C over m x dot plus K Over m x
equals zero this is kind of the normal
form that we're used to writing uh
higher order differential equations in
because from this you could read off the
characteristic equation and compute the
eigenvalues and e to the Lambda T's and
solve this system
um and so what we're going to do
is we're going to introduce these
variables
Omega naught equals the root of K Over N
and we're also going to introduce this
Zeta equals our damping coefficient
divided by 2 root k m and if I introduce
those two variables we can essentially
write our differential equation x double
dot
plus 2 Zeta
Omega not x dot
plus Omega naught squared x equals zero
now this looks like maybe I just made
things a lot more complicated by
introducing these but these Zeta and
Omega parameters are a much more natural
parameter system to understand the
Dynamics of this spring Mass damper so
specifically Omega is the natural
frequency
the natural frequency and that only
depends on the spring constant and the
mass and this damping coefficient here
this damping ratio this damping
ratio
this Zeta tells me if my system is over
damped or under damped or critically
damped so those are things you probably
remember from
um your your kind of differential
equations or physics class is that I
have these different cases so case one
would be
um
if Zeta is less than one this is under
damped
under damped and that means that the
system oscillates so system oscillates
with this frequency
so system oscillates
if
Zeta is greater than one and sorry I
grow such a bad Zeta if it's greater
than one then it's called over damped
and over damped means that basically it
does not oscillate so you let this Mass
go and it immediately goes back to rest
without overshooting and oscillating and
dying out so overdamped means it
actually has no oscillations and if you
like it means that the eigenvalues here
have no imaginary part the the the roots
of the characteristic equation the roots
of the quadratic you know the quadratic
formula if I wrote this down in the
characteristic form Lambda squared plus
two Zeta Omega not Lambda
plus Omega naught squared equals zero
and I solved for Lambda
for Zeta that are greater than one this
polynomial in Lambda The Roots have no
complex conjugate imaginary parts and so
there's no oscillation there's no sine
and cosine to that behavior this all of
course relies on what I taught you in
the earlier ordinary differential
equations lectures so if you don't know
what I'm talking about you need to
rewind to the characteristic equation in
the spring Mass damper lecture
so that's what overdamped means and if I
have Zeta equals one that's called
critically damped critically
damped
essentially what this
is in this form
uh Zeta and Omega give me some kind of
knobs to play with to change the
behavior really easily of my system
instead of changing M and K and c and
kind of just randomly guessing what will
make it oscillate and what won't by
making Zeta greater than one or less
than one I can make it oscillate or not
oscillate pretty simple okay and so this
is the the system we're going to
simulate with forward Euler and backward
Oiler and in particular I'm going to
turn this into a matrix system of first
order equations we've done this a lot of
times
and so the way we're going to do that is
we're going to introduce this variable x
dot equals maybe I'll just do it over
here
so I'm going to introduce my my variable
x dot equals V and V Dot equals all of
this stuff on the right so that would be
um
minus 2 Zeta
Omega naught V
minus Omega naught squared x and I can
write that as a system of differential
equations D DT
of X and V that's my state of my system
my X here D DT of X and V is going to
equal
0 1 and minus Omega naught squared and
minus 2 Zeta Omega naught
times x and V so this is a matrix system
of first order differential equations
and if you like this looks exactly like
x dot equals ax for some Vector X
so this is
um you know
this is my Vector X
dot this is my Matrix a
and this is my Vector X so this is the
system we're going to be simulating in
Python and in Matlab and specifically
what we're going to do is we're going to
step the system forward in discrete
Delta T's using our forward Euler and
backward Euler integration scheme
specifically using
this integration scheme
and this integration scheme since our
Dynamics are linear okay I'm going to
erase this fire up Python and Matlab and
we're going to code this up and play
around with things like Zeta and Omega
and delta T and look at the behavior of
these systems all right stay put
okay
so we are simulating this spring Mass
damper system so our spring
Mass
damper
I erased the little diagram there so
it's just my
Mass on a spring with some damper and
we're going to do this in Matlab and
then in Python and so I've actually
already coded this up I'm going to put a
link to the code in the description both
in Matlab and python so you can follow
along
is we've picked some you know Omega
natural frequency and some damping ratio
so Zeta here is a d Zeta and D are the
same thing I just didn't want to write
Zeta a bunch of times
and so this is my system my a matrix is
0 1 minus Omega squared minus 2 times
Zeta times Omega this is the right hand
side of x dot equals ax
and what we're going to do is we're
going to simulate this using forward
Euler using backward Euler and also
using a much more accurate scheme called
a fourth order runga Cutta and we're
going to compare those and we're going
to play around with things like delta T
maybe we'll change the natural frequency
and the damping ratio and we'll see how
those systems behave
so I'm going to start with the system
with a small delta T because remember
this is essentially using a finite
difference approximation of my
derivative and that is only accurate
when I use a small delta T so let's use
a really small 0.01 delta T here and
we're going to integrate from time 0 to
time Big T equals 10 with this initial
condition so this corresponds to an
initial position of two units with a
zero velocity that's what I mean by 2 0
is position zero velocity sorry position
two velocity zero
and then I'm going to walk you through
this forward Euler step and my backward
Oiler step
so for for
I basically am going to create this
state X big F that's my forward Euler
State and this is going to be a matrix
where each column is X and V at that
time step okay so it's going to be
advancing forward in time and so the
First Column is just X naught it's
literally just X not V naught and then
what I'm going to do is for each time
I'm going to take my kth column
here I am I'm going to take my kth
column and I'm going to multiply it by
this Matrix the identity plus delta T
times a times my kth column and that's
going to be my K plus 1 column that's
going to be x k plus 1. and I'm storing
all of these in a matrix so I can plot
them later you don't technically have to
store this in a big Matrix this is
actually really efficient inefficient
because I didn't even declare the size
of this Matrix so every time step it's
actually creating a whole new Matrix and
making it bigger and bigger and bigger
this is like terrible Matlab code bear
with me you could have pre-allocated
this as a big array or you didn't have
to save this as a matrix if you don't
care about plotting if you just want to
know the future trajectory but I want
the whole trajectory X at every
intermediate K so I'm saving them in
this big Matrix XF and again you can
convince yourself that this formula here
is exactly this formula here
okay starting with the zero you know the
the First Column is my initial condition
and then I'm going to plot
um the first position which is X if I
did x f 2 comma colon that would be
plotting the velocity but I'm just
plotting the position the first entry of
this
um the first row of my Matrix okay
so that's forward Euler then backward
Euler is very very similar
except now the update all of these are
going to be stored in XB so XB is again
a matrix where every column is the state
of my system at a different instant in
time so you know the First Column of X
backward Euler is just X naught and then
my um K plus one column my K plus one
state is going to equal the inverse of
my identity minus a delta T times my kth
column pretty simple to code this up in
Matlab because the inverse is easy for a
matrix it would be much harder for a
generic non-linear system x dot equals f
of x but it's easier for a linear system
to solve for this implicit Euler
okay so that's that uh similarly I'm
going to plot the X position and then
I'm going to show you I'm just going to
you know I'm going to plot these things
and I'm going to have a third plot which
is a much more accurate scheme called
fourth order runga and in a few lectures
I'm going to derive the fourth order
runga Cut I'm going to write it down how
to actually code this up and solve it
and we're going to look at its error
properties for now we're going to take
it for granted that it's just a really
good high order integrator to compare
against okay and so the way you do this
is it's actually built into Matlab this
ode45 is a adaptive step fourth order
runga Kata scheme so the Adaptive time
step allows you to bump the accuracy up
to fifth order actually but it's based
on a fourth order runga cut a Time
stepper and what this od45 function
expects as arguments it has three
arguments it expects the right hand side
of a differential equation ode function
the right hand side you know either a
times X or f of x it expects a time span
that we're integrating zero to Big T in
increments of delta T and it expects an
initial condition X naught okay and what
do I have here so I'm defining my ode
from like I could have defined a
function like a new function you know my
right hand side or my linear function or
my spring Mass damper function whatever
as a times x
but you can do this on the fly in line
in Matlab using this thing called a
function handle so what this does is it
defines a function of time and space and
I'm defining that function to be a times
x
because Matlab is expecting this ode
fund to possibly vary in time and space
even though this doesn't change in time
I'm telling Matlab that it's a function
of T comma X okay and so this is how you
integrate that right hand side really
really accurately with fourth order
runga cut it so I'm going to plot all
three of these and compare them and then
we're going to play around with the
system parameters and see what happens
okay good uh and then I have some
plotting commands to make sure that it
doesn't look terrible
okay good so this is the plot this is
what
um The System Dynamics so I must have
picked a
a damper D that was uh under damped so D
is less than one so this is under damped
which means it oscillates the mass
oscillates as it dies out and that's
exactly the behavior you see here is
that it started at position two and it's
oscillating as it dies out to zero this
is the position versus time and you can
see that all three of these agree pretty
accurately or pretty closely so for for
all intents and purposes in this example
the fourth order rangukata scheme is
kind of the truth because it's very
accurate and so that blue curve is kind
of the the truth here
and forward Oiler and backward Oiler are
the white and the yellow curves here and
so you can actually
maybe I'll zoom in a teeny tiny bit here
if I can
um yeah let's see if I can zoom in
right here
you'll actually see that forward Oiler
and backward Oiler kind of forward Oiler
overshoots and backward Oiler
undershoots compared to this uh very
accurate ode45 and remember just like
um
the finite difference derivatives the
forward difference and the backward
difference would kind of over predict or
under predict or when we did our left
rectangle Rule and right rectangle rule
integrals some of them would overpredict
and underpredict based on the slope it's
kind of the exact same thing here
because these are are you know different
Taylor series approximations to this
derivative x dot
can I change delta T okay so what I
would expect is that if I make delta T
even smaller all of my integrators
should get closer to each other they
should get more accurate because um you
know I haven't derived the error
properties yet but we're pretty sure
that these are going to you know
the the error will decrease when I make
delta T smaller here so I just made
delta T 10 times smaller let's see what
happens
now all three of these curves are
perfectly on top of each other they're
almost identical if I zoom in you can
see that they are different
let's try this
I'll zoom in a little and you'll see I
think that they actually technically are
a teeny tiny bit different but they're
much much closer than before so making
delta T smaller did make all of these
integrators better
and I would imagine that making delta T
bigger so that I just made it 10 times
smaller now I'm making it 10 times
bigger than my original case this should
make it all much worse
oh that's bad
so forward Oiler
went unstable
for a delta T of 0.1 this forward Euler
scheme actually went unstable it's
saying that the Dynamics are blowing up
to Infinity as time goes to Infinity
which we know is not true we know that
the actual system is damped and these
have you know negative real part of
their eigenvalues it's a stable system
you can check that in fact let's check
it right now let's look at you know I of
a
this has negative real part it is a
stable system
but somehow for a big enough delta T
this scheme blew up
and it's probably going to have to do
with the eigenvalues of this identity
plus delta T a
um in fact I bet that that thing has
unstable eigenvalues and we're going to
show that in the next lecture that for
some delta T this thing goes unstable
I'm pretty sure that backward Euler
remains stable here so what am I going
to do I'm going to comment out my
forward Euler so it doesn't mess
everything up
I'm gonna get rid of my Legend
and in fact my my backward Oiler is
still stable even for a very large delta
T of 0.1 now it's not very accurate it
doesn't really have the right Behavior
it's inaccurate but it's at least not
stable it's at least not blowing up to
Infinity okay
so this kind of shows a few things it
shows that
um I'll go back to my original delta T
equals 0.01 so for a moderate delta T
both integrators perform okay they're
not perfect and making delta T smaller
makes them more accurate
but for a big enough delta T this
forward Oiler went unstable so that's a
huge limitation of this method is that
it is very prone to instability for even
moderately large Delta T's okay and I'll
tell you why in the next lecture why
this thing is unstable for large Delta
T's it's pretty interesting and it's
related to the eigenvalues of this
Matrix here whereas my implicit Oiler
was still stable even for that larger
delta T it was very inaccurate but it
was more stable
a big enough delta T even this one will
go unstable but it's much much much more
stable in general than this scheme here
okay I think that's pretty much
everything I wanted to show you in
Matlab so now I'm going to switch to
Python and we're going to kind of go
over the same stuff all right
okay good so we have derived these
equations of motion x dot equals ax for
the spring Mass damper system it is a
linear system so it's x dot equals ax
with this a matrix this a matrix has
um eigenvalues with negative real part
which means the system is stable so for
any you know real damping the system is
going to be stable you can check that
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to simulate the the we're going to
predict a trajectory of the system we're
going to simulate the system forward in
time using forward Euler and backward
Oiler in Python and we're also going to
compare this against a third integration
scheme which is called a fourth order
runga Cutta scheme I am going to derive
it in a future lecture and we're going
to analyze it a bunch but for now we're
just going to take for granted that
fourth order rangakata is a very very
accurate integrator much more accurate
than these and that's going to serve as
our kind of ground true for this example
so we're going to compare these against
a much more accurate integrator and see
how these perform
okay so I'll just walk you through this
it's pretty simple I should probably run
these good okay good so we've defined
our Omega and our damping ratio and so
here I've renamed Zeta as D because I
didn't want to type Zeta a bunch of
times but D and zet are the same thing
D equals 0.25 so it equals 0.25 is under
damped so it's less than one so it means
we're going to get oscillations in this
system that's good and we're defining
our linear spring Mass damper system our
a matrix as an array 0 1 minus Omega
squared and minus 2 Zeta times
Omega
and we're going to start by integrating
with a small delta T .01 because again
both of these schemes are based on a
finite difference derivative of x dot
and we know that finite difference
derivatives are only accurate for small
delta T so we're going to start with a
small delta T we're going to integrate
from time 0 to time Big T So 10 full
time units in increments of 0.01 and
we're going to start with an initial
condition of 2 0 which corresponds to a
position of 2 and a velocity of zero so
2 0 means a position of two and I let
this go with zero velocity
and then we're going to integrate
through forward Euler we're going to
integrate through backward Oiler and I'm
going to compare against that more
accurate fourth order ode solver I
talked about
so forward oil is really simple it
literally just
um
this is some stuff you need to kind of
you know
um some Preamble but the real code is
down here so what we're doing is we're
storing our forward Euler trajectory in
this array XF x times x big F
and so this is a matrix with you know
each column is a state X and v x and v x
and v x and V at each time instance so
the First Column of XF is my initial
condition the second column is going to
be X1
the third column is going to be X2 the
fourth column is X3 and so on and so
forth and again remember that we start
our indexing at zero in Python so this
big XF array is going to store my
trajectory as it evolves in time so the
whole first row is going to be a
trajectory of my position the whole
second row is a trajectory of my
velocity
and this line here is this forward Euler
update so it says that the K plus month
entry the K plus one step in my
trajectory is going to be my kth term my
kth term
times an identity plus DT times a okay a
two by two identity plus a delta T times
my kth x equals my K plus 1 x so this is
the update and we basically write a for
Loop so we keep constantly stepping this
thing forward and updating it and
building this uh trajectory x f
uh where now what we're doing is we're
storing it in this x b array the exact
same trajectory information every column
is my state at an instant in time we
initialize it so the First Column is my
initial condition X naught and now the
update I'll scroll over a little so you
can see
uh this is unfortunate let me make this
a teeny bit bigger
the update uh the K plus month entry of
this backward Euler scheme
is the case
State XK
times I minus a delta T inverse this is
NP dot lineage dot P inverse that's the
inverse of identity minus a delta T
times x k
so again all that we're doing here is
we're just coding up this uh this
backward Euler integration scheme again
these are only the ones I've actually
written down here are only for linear x
dot equals ax but it's much easier to
solve this implicit backward Euler for
linear Dynamics because it's just a
matrix inversion okay so now we have
forward Euler we have backward Oiler and
then we're going to plot those
trajectories and we're going to plot
them against this fourth order rangakata
fourth order rangakuta is pretty easy in
Python there is this solve ivp solve
initial value problem where it takes in
an ode function that literally means the
right hand side of a DX DT equals ode
function and here we've defined our ode
function to be a times x because we know
that x dot equals a times x and we're
integrating from time 0 to T with
initial condition X naught pretty simple
so I'm going to run this
and now we're going to plot all of our
data here so this is our X position uh
we're just plotting you know
let me
scroll up
we're plotting
um our forward Euler our backward Oiler
and our fourth order runga Cutta and
we're plotting the
first row which corresponds to our
position kind of the the zero index here
means our first row that's the X
position in time so this is literally a
plot of X in time and as you expect if I
pull this thing to a unit 2 and let it
go it's going to oscillate and die out
that's what we see here it oscillates
and dies out and in particular you
actually see that forward Euler and
backward Oiler are pretty close to the
the much more accurate fourth order
runka Cutta this ode45
and forward Oiler overshoots a little
bit and backward Oiler undershoots a
little bit so this one's a little bit
more unstable and this one's a little
bit more damped or more stable and you
can see that here you can also plot the
velocities if you like kind of the same
story not much new information by
plotting the velocities but you can plot
that
so what do we want to do now now I think
what would be interesting is to do
things like let's change the delta T
okay so we know that because these are
based on a finite difference derivatives
if I make my delta T smaller
it should make both of these integrals
more accurate so if I do that I'm going
to run this for a smaller delta T and
now when I plot these curves should get
closer together because they're all
going to be more accurate
and in fact yes they all now collapse on
top of each other because I made my
delta T 10 times smaller which means
that I've made everything much more
accurate I haven't told you how much
more accurate yet I'm going to derive
the accuracy of these schemes in the
next lecture but we know because they're
based on Taylor series that making delta
T smaller should make them more accurate
up to some power of delta T and that's
exactly what we see here
now let's try making delta T
um
instead of making it smaller let's make
it 10 times bigger so go from 0.01 to
0.1
same thing now I'm going to plot
oh no something went really wrong here
with forward Euler so forward Oiler
actually went unstable
and it's not like the system went
unstable the spring Mass damper system
is still stable the Omega and Zeta
didn't change all I changed was delta T
of my integrator so the system should
still be a damped oscillation but
forward Euler is blowing up to Infinity
so again this is something I'm going to
tell you a lot in the next lecture is
how to analyze the stability of these
integrators for different delta T and
long story short I think we all know
that it's going to have something to do
with the eigenvalues of this operator
identity plus delta T A and inverse of
identity minus Delta ta these are going
to have eigenvalues and those
eigenvalues are going to tell me if my
system blows up for some delta T and
what we found here is that for big delta
T forward Euler is unstable and blows up
if I omit this plot if I just let's say
I just omit my forward Euler
okay I'm just gonna
only plot backward Oiler and rangakata
actually backward Oiler is still stable
the yellow curve here even for a big
delta T it still converges to zero it's
very inaccurate it doesn't it doesn't
match the true behavior of the system
hardly at all but at least it doesn't
blow up to Infinity so for a big delta T
forward Euler went unstable and backward
Oiler was still stable even though it's
very inaccurate so we'll understand both
of those when we start looking at the
eigenvalues of this that's kind of a
generic property of forward and backward
Euler is that forward Euler tends to be
very finicky and unstable for for even
moderate Delta T's whereas backward
Euler is typically much more stable
still not that accurate but much more
stable okay and I'll just go back to my
original delta T equals 0.01
and we'll plot it one more time just to
leave all of these up
okay let's run that one more time and
again this was uh for a moderate but
small delta T of 0.01 it behaves kind of
like you'd expect
okay good that's what I wanted to show
you today is how to code these up and
how to play around with the Delta T's
and see what happens I think what I'm
going to do then in the next lecture as
I've alluded to several times in the
next lecture what I'm going to do is we
are now going to look at the error
properties the error properties
um you know what is the error as a is it
order delta T is it order Delta t
squared we're going to get these from
the Taylor series
um you know of f of x of t plus delta T
and things like that and we're also
going to look at the stability
the stability as a function of delta T
so when I make delta T bigger or smaller
how did the stability of these two
numerical schemes change okay that's all
coming up thank you
[Music]